hi there I'm Anna Prosser Robinson for  GameSpot here on the frontline at San  Diego comic-con 2014 this is the first  thing I've done at San Diego comic-con  and if you can see where I'm standing  you will notice that I'm in quite a  precarious position I am at the  Assassin's Creed unity obstacle course  and I'm about to take the leap of faith  I've always wondered if I could measure  up to what I do in video games so I  guess we'll see if I can jump into a  hay-bale just like an assassin  normally I'm just a three-to-one jump  kind of girl but that is so much higher  from up there than it looks down here I  had my knees bent ready to go and just  couldn't make my legs jump the first  couple times but I did it you saw it  give me a rating how was my jump on a  scale of one to ten tweet at me at Anna  Prosser on my brand new Samsung Galaxy  s5 and let me know what you thought